it is always quite the spectacle never a
goose step out of place or a berry
outside
but this was a slimmed Down Parade just
8 000 troops a lot fewer than last year
and much less hits
because what Russia still has it leads
on the battlefield and not on Red Square
flanked by veterans this is a moment the
president enjoys the memory of World War
II is the Patriotic glue he uses to hold
his people together in a face of what
he's long described as a marauding and
decadent West
their goal and there's nothing new here
to achieve the disintegration and
destruction of our country to cross out
the results of World War II to finally
break the system of Global Security in
international law
this is the reason for the catastrophe
that Ukrainian people are currently
experiencing they became a hostage to
the coup d'etat and on that basis was
built the criminal regime of its Western
Masters a bargaining chip in the
realization of their cruel selfish plans
there was a time when Western leaders
would take part in all of this but not
anymore this time just leaders from
former Soviet republics invited last
minute and not quite prepared to
relinquish old alliances some more
dependent on Russia than others
regular muscovites were kept well away
the parade canceled and another two
dozen cities
this is the closest the general public
here in Moscow get to this parade they
just see the hardware coming out of red
square right at the end real tail end of
the procession stuff not what they got
out of bed for this morning
so most watched Along on their mobile
phones
I think the parade is nice and it's
necessary in Russia but some of the
vehicles that are used there may be used
in Ukraine
it's all the US and Ukraine's tricks our
grandfathers should have finished them
off better they should have finished
them off in 45 so that this wouldn't be
happening now
one soldier's mother meeting Vladimir
Putin clutching the picture of her son
killed in Ukraine
but there are so many more whose numbers
aren't yet counted on how many will
Russia remember when all this is done
[Music]